Any numpy array has a number of
attributes that describes it.
In addition to the elements it contains.
One of the most useful one is shape.
Essentially a tuple containing
the number of rows and
columns are height and
width of the array.
We have already seen how to
specify this when creating arrays.
The shape of the array A would
be five rows and four columns.
So this is your array.
Now let's see how to access
the shape of the given array
by using the shape attribute.
a.shape will give you
the shape of the array.
Let's run it.
Array.shape will return you a tuple
with the first value specifying
the number of rows.
And the second value specifying
the number of columns.
Next we will learn how to
individually access number of rows or
number of columns.
a.shape[0] would return
the number of rows and
a.shape[1] would return
the number of columns.
Let's check the output.
Here you will see that the number of
rows are correctly extracted as five.
And number of columns as 4.
If you have more dimensions,
you will have additional
elements in the shape tuple.
The number of dimensions in an array
can be found by simply asking for
the length of this tuple.
a.shape will return a tuple and
the length of that tuple would inform
us what is the dimension of the array.
It rightly tells us that the dimension
of the defined array A is 2.
Okay, how about total number
of elements in an array?
Yes for a 2D array, it will be the
product of number of rows and columns.
But if you had more dimension,
this calculation could
be a little complicated.
Fortunately we can retrieve
the number of elements directly using
size attributes.
a.size will give us the number of
elements present in the array A.
We can expect the output to be
the product of the rows and
the columns which is 5 into 4,
which is 20.
Let's check it.
As we expected, the output is 20 which
means there are 20 values in the array.
Attributes like size and shape
are very useful when you have to over
array elements to perform
some computation.
You can also access the data
type of each element using
the D type attribute of the array.
Let's check the data type of
the values present in array A.
In this case, our array elements
are of the type float64.
That is 64-bit floating point numbers.